more to you man mm-hmm you people don't
know when you were younger you liked
hip-hop a lot oh yeah a little bit the
Rice Krispies Wow there are three of
three white Jews my dad's not but my two
other friends were like they're like Jew
they look Jewish I was like these three
Jews in clothes that were 70 sizes too
big going to the underaged clubs that
were around then enough they still are
now yeah we would go battle dance crews
in the 80s 1990 yeah Wow yeah we're like
sighs for teacher bows and what would
your book like completely insane yeah
would you win I know no we try yeah we
had we before we went out we've come to
my house and we'd have like dance
practice good let's work on some floor
work and there for hours you would do
that oh yeah yeah oh my god how sad oh
dude there's this black dude named was
logic he was a DJ this cool guy and he
we're like let's go to logic house cuz
logic was like helping as Wow how long
for a couple years you know we used to
smoke a ton of weed and it's freestyle
and yeah you know but when you but when
you would go on vacation you like to
drink it yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm not a
real laugh I know I smoke a lot of pot
but still now yeah it's not even a drug
it's not no do you do the medical thing
or do you go dude well I live in
Colorado for a year and a half so it's
recreational you know I never had a card
I never had like a medical go wow but I
didn't smoke pot for a long
and in the last two or three years I
just love it I mean it's I'd rather have
like a half a joint and then have three
or four whiskey's or whatever you know
you put the kids to bed you know smoke a
little bit and chill watch TV get
creative you know I just it's a great
great escape you just you know I'll be
honest with you man you you're just
really just a surprise because um when I
got the show I googled you
you know I mean I watch stuff you know I
mean Google just to see you know and
then meeting you
we had dinner that one night right and
you just you just unlike what I thought
you were gonna be like that's not in a
great way anyhow because you see you
know you see a lot of these guys that
are um you know you're a leading man you
know whatever you've done things before
you know me and whatnot people know who
you are and usually sometimes they just
your people become [ __ ] you know
I mean and you're just like you don't
seem like you're an actor really no I'm
being real this is me being sentimental
and and trying to give a compliment I
hey I'm not gonna compliment I'm not
gonna take you're right because like
even though like a lot of people that
you've met they're perfectly nice people
but you still get that thin layer of
Hollywood slime yeah you kind of you
know what I mean it's it's there yeah I
mean Chris D'Elia for instance which
people say say they look like him yeah
have you heard that I've heard that no I
agree I think it's a long hairs
um I have no idea I don't know yeah what
is that anyway but anyway D'Elia is also
a very nice guy very funny you know you
know but there is this there was a
cockiness you know I mean and a little
bit of like I know it's dick right yeah
but there's something there that's a
little wild you know man mm he's got
he's little he lets it run wild you know
his ego mm-hmm right which is I'm fine
with it I these a great he's a great guy
right but you don't have that either
though well I think that's probably you
don't have like look at my [ __ ] truck
or
I'm not saying and I don't know I don't
know Chris great guy and a couple
everything about saying he's an insecure
person know what I'm saying is like I
feel pretty secure and Who I am and
you're more secure that you're way more
secure than crystal okay I know and I
love I just like I like I love people
you know what I mean people I love
people people look interesting yeah and
I hate I'm a very detail-oriented person
so I don't want to have a comp a
[ __ ] conversation with anyone so
I'll ask questions that aren't normally
asked when I'm conversing with somebody
because of having [ __ ] small talk
like we are we are about our details
that's who we are
yeah what I mean so if I'm gonna have a
conversation with someone let's talk
about our details so we actually go
somewhere and have an interesting
dialogue rather than [ __ ] you know
yeah and I have to be open to have that
as does the person's refreshing though
because a lot of people are at least in
LA they really like to live on the
surface of things it's like let's get to
know you what I can get out of you and
we'll leave it at that
mmm-hmm so like the the details are
never exchanged no I know I know that's
what the [ __ ] is the point of me wasting
my breath if I know if I walk away from
here right from this conversation
knowing nothing else but your name and
your profession right or what I could
possibly get out of this interaction
right it's [ __ ] yeah like I ask
people what they make about I don't ever
wanna take a guess what do you think you
would guess well I can only bit base on
what I'm making okay well yeah it's like
a triple it I won't tell you but but
just I wanted to someone what do you
what do you think you kept assaut what
is your perception right what do you
what yeah yeah
a hundred grand no okay that's okay so
more at last can you say that it's it's
less whether that's it that's it yeah
makes ninety-nine Greg well that's where
that's really uh really because in my
you know I saw because being a being you
know it's fine I'm just happy to be
working I'm never gonna ask for more I
like what I make mm-hm
it's great money but what it what you
know like you know a lot of ethnic
people go well the white man you know
makes this much more alright but being
the lead and this net you in your head
but you know what at the end of the day
I don't give a [ __ ] because I'm just
grateful to I really am grateful to have
that job okay you know we all it's a
great job you know it's a tough and
anyone listening right now I make
$20,000 we all right and that's a lot of
money for me and I get half of it to
charity
the will we spied on spinal right I give
money to yeah
like 9 Porto Rican kids have 9 metals
new spines plays like titanium yeah yeah
now use adamantium steel good [ __ ]
charity
is there anything that you want to plug
the show
[Music]